en río de janeiro este año no retumba la
alegre y ensordecedora percusión
el sambódromo normalmente epicentro de
la fiesta se ha convertido en un
memorial para las víctimas del virus se
iluminará todas las noches en honor a
más de 238.000 muertos que deja la
pandemia en brásil
no habrá carnaval porque queremos salvar
vidas no habrá carnaval porque tenemos
que preservar vidas
entre los más afectados por estas ayudas
de nostalgia brasileña los comerciantes
las playas los bares y los restaurantes
siguen abiertos pero la ocupación
hotelera ronda el 50 por ciento
en comparación con otros años todo está
paralizado rezamos y agradecemos lo poco
que sigue llegando pero sin carnaval no
hay paso algunos tratan de guardar la
alegría propia de estas fechas
en el gimnasio voy a dar una clase en la
piscina y me pondré esta máscara para
celebrar el carnaval como sea
es un poco raro salir con esta pandemia
con el caos mundial pero aún así te las
arreglas para divertirte con tus amigos
golpeado con fuerza por la segunda ola
de contagios brasil sigue hundido en una
grave crisis sanitaria rondando los 10
millones de casos confirmados esto
sumado a una campaña de vacunación
caótica y con retrasos